[主播] 注意我们的一个粉丝同学生日快乐。
[主播] 背面，所以哪哪背面有？
[嘉宾] 刚才那个检测报告。
[主播] 啊，检测报告后面有个祝粉丝朋友生日快乐。
[嘉宾] 现在直播间里十万多人。
[主播] 肯定有，今天是生日的。
[主播] 今天我们直播间里十万多人肯定有过生日的。
[嘉宾] 对啊。
[嘉宾] 一年365天。
[主播] 我们能不能给一个人送上一箱？
[主播] 不能是吧？
[嘉宾] 其实有这种要求当然也可以。
[主播] 我这种要求也可以，我现在可以给大家送上一箱野山大麦芽对吧？
[嘉宾] 怎么送？
[主播] 看怎么送。
[主播] 一会我提问的时候，谁第一个回答出来，我就给谁送。
[主播] 可以吗？
[嘉宾] 行。
[主播] 知识。
[主播] 让大家知道知识是有用的。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 虽然它只是一个小用。
[嘉宾] 可以找客服小姐姐。
[主播] 可以，随后找客服小姐姐记录啊。
[主播] 刚才加入我们那个会员体系之后呢，像有这种包啊什么的，你平时买东西他是有券是可以给你送的。
[主播] 肉夹馍，肉夹馍有吗？
[嘉宾] 肉夹馍今天有。
[主播] 有有，给大家上一下，老潼关肉夹馍啊。
[嘉宾] 给大家放二号吧。
[主播] 放二号链接。
[主播] 有朋友要肉夹馍给你上啊。
[嘉宾] 但是我们没有样品了，所以。
[主播] 没有样品不影响，大家先上吧。
[嘉宾] 先开吧。
[主播] 我记得他们说寄了样品了，你问一下吧。
[嘉宾] 寄的不如吃得快。
[主播] 就刚寄来就吃完了。
[嘉宾] 你自己吃了多少个你没有数吧？
[主播] 我总共吃过两个。
[嘉宾] 就吃过两个啊。
[嘉宾] 那就是石棉吃的。
[主播] 所以大能力的那个就是因为我跟石棉都是陕西人嘛。
[主播] 哎呀，一看到那个肉夹馍的饼子真的忍不住。
[主播] DNA都动了。
[主播] 碳水狂魔的兴奋呢。
[主播] 尤其加上一些这个炒的榨菜，太香了。
[主播] 香喷喷的拍啊。
[主播] 橄榄油。
[主播] 西班牙安达卢西亚的橄榄油。
[主播] 到了夏天，大家如果家里是拌菜的话，我建议用橄榄油吃啊。
[主播] 还有一个就是家里有孩子和老人的话。
[主播] 成年人其实因为你身体的代谢能力和解渴能力很好，所以其实饮食上。
[主播] 可能还没有太大的要求，坦诚来说。
[主播] 但是孩子和老人其实可以让他们多吃一些这个橄榄油。
[主播] 当然如果你家里这个比如条件允许对吧，你觉得买一瓶油这瓶油能拌菜也能吃很久呢。
[主播] 你每次拌菜你能用多少啊？
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 半年，三个月。
[主播] 我估计都够了。
[主播] 拌菜的时候放上橄榄油，尤其到了夏天，大家都喜欢吃那种拌的凉菜，对吧？
[主播] 橄榄油因为它里头富含各种不饱和脂肪酸。
[主播] 这人身体比较好啊。
[主播] 这个也是我们自己做的橄榄油，所以它的呃是可以用券的。
[主播] 刚才给大家点击那个是可以用券的啊，Olive oil。
[主播] 怎么了？
[嘉宾] 我才看到。
[主播] 看到啥了？
[嘉宾] 橄榄油的那个。
[嘉宾] 我自个都没发现。
[主播] 啊。
[嘉宾] 咱家的油。
[主播] 这啊，导演说我们自己的橄榄油在抖音里头的会员体系里头他们有一个关于这个的排名。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 我们的排名在。
[主播] 这个可能是因为最近一段时间咱直播间里人多。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 但是第一个排名不能说明问题。
[主播] 我必须得先理性的承认，对吧？
[主播] 那是因为我们直播间最近一段时间人多呀。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 但是我有理由相信这个橄榄油大家买完第一次之后，如果是真的懂橄榄油，他会回来，他如果需要他还会再买第二次的。
[主播] 如果他愿意去买第二次，愿意去买第三次的时候，那说明这个油就品质真的好了。
[主播] 就有一天如果咱直播间里，比如说大家有一天都不愿意来听我们这胡说八道了，但是他有想要买橄榄油，他还是会来这买，那如果我们还是第一名的话。
[主播] 我觉得那说明真正的证明这个产品是好产品了。
[主播] 对吧？
[嘉宾] 没毛病。
[主播] 没毛病啊。
[主播] 有朋友说那个包能不能挂个链接，咱那个包。
[主播] 你问一下。
[嘉宾] 挂。
[主播] 就是咱挎的这个包。
[嘉宾] 会员。
[嘉宾] 会员会送。
[主播] 我知道你是送的，那有人说我就想套钱买呢。
[嘉宾] 买是吧？
[嘉宾] 不可以。
[主播] 这怎么能又不可以这种说法呢，你你你。
[主播] 你想办法肯定是 可以的。
[主播] 啊。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 不存在不可以。
[主播] 对吧？
[嘉宾] 没有不可能。
[主播] 真的是，主动一些，什么都有可能。
[主播] 来，橄榄油大家想要自己拍的啊。
[主播] 我嘴里刚吃啥呢，我是刚才吃了这个我杯子里泡的我们自己做的枸杞。
[主播] 但是今天的已经完了。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 泡了两包。
[嘉宾] 反正公司的样品。
[主播] 我自己都舍不得，我自己一包枸杞平时泡好几天呢。
[主播] 枸杞嚼着中间的籽，挺甜的。
[嘉宾] 这个桃也很甜。
[主播] 桃是吧？
[主播] 蟠桃。
[嘉宾] 哎，今天价格也很美丽。
[嘉宾] 44块9,到手4.5斤到5斤。
[主播] 啊，对于蟠桃来说价格还行，因为蟠桃本身价格出价就高啊。
[主播] 有朋友说让我出题。
[主播] 可以。
[主播] 出题是吧？
[主播] 咱那个长江黄河那两本书准备好了没？
[嘉宾] 还在准备，看商家的链接有点问题。
[主播] 可以。
[嘉宾] 稍等一下，稍等一下。
[主播] 我要出题，我出题一会抽中的是可以给大家第一个回答的，可以给大家送一个那个什么对吧？
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 但是我这看到的可能和实际评论区第一个是不一样的，就我就说是我看到的第一个回答正确。
[嘉宾] 你实际的那个名字，你念他名字就行了。
[主播] 可以，好好，我一会念个名字啊。
[主播] 我还可以给大家送东西，我的天哪。
[主播] 别逼我。
[主播] 一开心把什么都送了。
[主播] 连我自己上架。
[嘉宾] 送了。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 千金散去还复来啊。
[主播] 鲜花。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 花出去就开心了。
[主播] 帆布包刚给大家展示了一下，这是我们自己的帆布包。
[主播] 加入会员体系之后买东西有积分，积分够了我其实就可以送你，但是如果你说你自己想要套钱买一个，我们给大家找。
[主播] 其实帆布包有很多的，我相信大家可能买可能会买到比我们更好看的一些，如果说你您不喜欢这个图画的话，您可能也买到自己合适的。
[主播] 我是比较建议大家就开始背这种简单的帆布包。
[主播] 我反而觉得背个这，然后呢你去商场。
[主播] 你也一样的优雅，而且我觉得你一看就是一个非常重视环境的人，对吗？
[嘉宾] 重视环保。
[主播] 重视环保的人。
[主播] 我不觉得背个这，就比背个几万块那种包钱的。
[嘉宾] 挺好看的。
[主播] 对不对？
[主播] 就是我我坦诚来说，如果我自己走在商场里，或者走在路上，我看到有人背这种包，我就会觉得这个人很有教养。
[主播] 而且他很有这种环保的意识。
[主播] 就可能跟几万块那种鳄鱼皮啊，鸵鸟皮做的就不一样。
[主播] 因为确实有那些嘛，对吧？
[嘉宾] 这个桃子你尝过没？
[主播] 桃子。
[主播] 没有尝过。
[嘉宾] 你是不是应该吃一斤了？
[主播] 我尝过。
[主播] 对。
[嘉宾] 我们吃。
[主播] 真的真的很甜。
[嘉宾] 吃过留留一点，下次有可能还要用。
[嘉宾] 留着有用。
[主播] 很甜。
[嘉宾] 真的没吃过。
[主播] 给。
[主播] 把大的给你。
[嘉宾] 还是给我好。
[主播] 样品是，现在就剩一个小的展示的啊。
[主播] 大的给楠楠吃了。
[主播] 包我们给大家找啊，别急。
[主播] 买不买都行，直播间里大家带着舒服就行。
[主播] 带着舒服就行。
[主播] 因为我知道可能前两天很多朋友，我也我经常也会看抖音。
[主播] 都会看这几天很多抖音的私信。
[主播] 然后呢。
[主播] 有时候我我会回答什么，就比如说哪个朋友告诉我快递磕碰了。
[主播] 产品真的有问题，我会第一时间截图发给我们的客服。
[主播] 我会让给大家迅速解决，这第一个。
[主播] 第二我会回答很多学生问的问题，比如说读什么书呀。
[主播] 啊，还有我会我会给大家有的人回复，比如说。
[主播] 他人生中遇到了很多的难，或者他最近一段时间在直播间里听完之后感觉到找到人生的力量。
[主播] 其实我觉得是他自己内心的觉醒，其实并不倒不一定真的是我我们说的东西有多用。
[主播] 我们都年纪尚轻，经验尚浅，胡说八道能有什么用？
[主播] 然后也有一些朋友说他开始看书了。
[主播] 我会非常感动。
[主播] 就我觉得看到这些行为的时候，说明我的部分的言行。
[主播] 实际上在积德行善。
[主播] 然后呢，我也看到了很多朋友前段时间替我们的担心，比如说。
[主播] 董老师你直播间里十几万人，那按照你们这个比例你们一天应该卖成一个亿才行。
[主播] 但实际上你们并没有卖那么多。
[主播] 然后大家可能我能理解，因为大家说再商言商嘛，对吧？
[主播] 你就好好卖你的菜，你好正钱就行了。
[主播] 你应该好好利用这个机会去挣钱。
[主播] 如果是那样的话，我可能就不是我了。
[主播] 你觉得呢？
[主播] 喜欢买就买，不喜欢买就带一带也行，你觉得呢？
[主播] 不强求啊。
[主播] 商场每天你去逛也不见得你要进店啊。
[主播] 是不是？
[主播] 我非常呼吁大家开始看书。
[主播] 因为我我今天早上还收到一个我们的老朋友啊。
[主播] 可儿你记得吧？
[主播] 从去年冬天就一直关注，咱开播就关注到现在，可儿。
[主播] 可儿今天早上给我发私信，他说。
[主播] 他说他一个在抖音上给我发私信。
[主播] 他说他一个单位的朋友，一个男同事，以前从来都不看书，这几天开始看书了。
[嘉宾] 因为看了直播间。
[主播] 而且真的看书之后就把手机放下越来越多了。
[主播] 你看抖音就是一个非常有智慧的软件。
[主播] 你知道前一段时间咱特别火的时候，抖音让我帮忙拍了很多视频都是什么，呼吁大家善与结善缘。
[主播] 而不是每天靠一种就是那种负面信息吸引大家的注意。
[主播] 然后上热搜，然后不断，你这越来越多的负面信息，负面消息上热搜，最后吸引的都是什么人？
[主播] 或者激发的是大家的什么情绪？
[主播] 是恶语情绪。
[嘉宾] 环境会改变一个人的。
[主播] 这真的是环境会改变一个人。
[主播] 但大家最后都不可能这个善与结善缘了。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 都是恶语相向，极端的讽刺和羞辱。
[主播] 所以不不靠他们不靠那种恶性的事件去吸引人的注意。
[主播] 然后第二个就是前段时间鼓励读书，我们让我们读唐诗，然后搞唐诗配音这种。
[主播] 我觉得这个东西就是真的功德一件。
[主播] 你你不能说抖音现在日活好像说七亿人。
[主播] 不可能说七亿人全部受影响，也不可能七千万人受影响。
[主播] 也不可能七百人受影响。
[主播] 有个七十万人，或者七万人。
[主播] 或者再小的七千人读书，这七千人里头万一以后有一个人。
[主播] 就是昨天我跟苏老师在这聊那个。
[嘉宾] 其实我都买了二三本书了。
[主播] 你都买了二三本书了。
[主播] 你都不觉得丢人，你才买了二三本书。
[主播] 你该多买几本书看。
[主播] 啊，然后导演跟我说其实我都买了二三本书了。
[主播] 这个对不起啊，我刚。
[主播] 出于一个第一反应先刺激了他。
[主播] 导演你有没有感觉到现在受到了刺激？
[嘉宾] 稍微有一点。
[主播] 有一点，你有没有决定看书？
[嘉宾] 我一定决定了，不然买来干啥？
[主播] 对，你其实不用买，咱这那么多书呢，你看就行了。
[主播] 然后这个以前当老师的时候啊。
[主播] 就就是每一个学生你要关注到他。
[主播] 你也不知道这个孩子以后长大后能成什么才，坦诚来说，对吧？
[主播] 因为你现在回忆一下你以前初中小学那班里，是不是学习不好的孩子都混得都不好，是不是？
[主播] 不见得。
[主播] 也是不是学习好的孩子混得都好？
[主播] 也不见得。
[主播] 因为我们知道人的赛道，人生拉的时间维度越长。
[主播] 就是时间维度拉长，真正重要的东西才会得以体现。
[主播] 这句话是我以前经常给孩子们说的。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 时间维度拉长，真正的价值感才得以体现。
[主播] 价值感不是学历，不是一个正出。
[主播] 价值感是，注意，各位朋友们，学历不等于学习力。
[主播] 这是两个事情。
[主播] 证书不等于一个人会一直读书，你懂我的意思没？
[主播] 就不是不是说名校学毕业的孩子能力一定强，那真不简单。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 学习力是不仅是读书，在任何事情中都虚心求教，不断地突破自我，砸破再成长，对吧，突破自我。
[主播] 那个叫学习力。
[主播] 学历是一张证书，那你如果真学历有用，那大家就会觉得卖学历就行了。
[主播] 有吧？
[主播] 就有歪门邪道的人只想获得学历，但其实这两者没有对等关系的。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 所以这个这个不一样。
[主播] 买书不等于读书。
[主播] 现在大家是开始买书，但是我其实更呼吁是最后大家读书。
[主播] 如果我们直播间里最后，比如说每天可能只有五六千人，但是大家都狠爱读书。
[主播] 那我觉得也是功德一件。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 来，黑猪肉，导演你有什么话想表达？
[嘉宾] 我觉得我最近虽然是看的时间不是很长，但我偶尔确实也会翻一翻，因为就在桌子旁边，买了三三本书。
[嘉宾] 但是放在桌子旁边我我也会翻一翻。
[主播] 书偶尔翻一翻，嗯。
[主播] 因为现在大家的生活很难有，哎，包括这个桃没吃完，你把桃拿哪去了？
[主播] 没吃完你给我，你别浪费了。
[主播] 你不敢扔了。
[主播] 糟蹋粮食啊。
[主播] 你给我拿来放这，我一会还吃呢。
[主播] 这句我拿这个半给你拿一下。
[主播] 好好，谢谢。
[主播] 那个完整的你拿走吧。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 没事没事没事。
[主播] 你放这个纸上，你把那个拿走。
[主播] 就是现在让大家完整的大的时间段去读书，真的很难。
[主播] 对不对？
[主播] 工作那么忙，晚上回家我还要做饭，还要照顾孩子。
[主播] 董老师你以为人都跟你一样，每天闲得没事干，站着说话不腰疼，咱俩就说我们读书。
[主播] 你来过一过我的日子试一试，我一大早七点就起来了，要照顾孩子，要做早餐。
[主播] 把孩子送到学校，我去单位里忙一天。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 你以为我跟你一样清闲。
[主播] 当然我能理解大家。
[主播] 所以我给大家说的是不是要求你每天都大时间地去读书。
[主播] 比如说你晚上睡觉前。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 你在床头放一本。
[主播] 你在沙发上放一本。
[主播] 你最后把书直接摆在电视机前面。
[主播] 你刚躺下，啊，准备看个综艺。
[主播] 哎呀，你看前面。
[主播] 额尔古纳河右岸。
[主播] 额尔古纳河右岸难道没有这个综艺节目吸引你吗？
[主播] 大兴安岭森林里的秘密和森林间散落的那些星星。
[主播] 难道没有那些嘻嘻哈哈的这个节目吸引你吗？
[主播] 它太吸引了，我告诉你。
[主播] 一种是这种消耗式的满足，一种是这种补充式的满足。
[主播] 不好意思。
[主播] 坐那儿就把书就翻开了。
[主播] 你哪怕看两页呢。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 有的朋友反馈说这几天看完书之后睡眠都好了。
[主播] 这这算有用啊，对吧？
[主播] 以前呢到晚上翻来覆去的看视频，看视频看到半夜睡不着。
[主播] 这几天刚拿出，哎呀，董老师我一会开始进入状态了。
[主播] 这个在锅里头炸到最后，它已经水分彻底蒸发完了之后，我天，那个油的香味飘得到处都是，你在院子里都能闻到那个香味。
[主播] 哇，那个香味可太棒了。
[主播] 你知道农村啊，家里头平常比如说物质比较匮乏，大家吃着可能比较就是白面，对吧，或者吃着一些比较简单的菜。
[主播] 只要你拿出就瞌睡。
[主播] 这也算一个功劳啊，对吧？
[主播] 把你以前晚上那些焦虑，发那些伤感的朋友圈，废旧的动态，全部都省略了。
[主播] 怎么样能让大家在干了一天体力活之后，迅速的补充体力呢？
[主播] 因为大家想吃啊。
[主播] 想吃，那你就得让原本简单的食物有更好的味道。
[主播] 通过读书改善你自己的睡眠。
[主播] 不用担心说我为什么一看书就瞌睡呢？
[主播] 用勺子到那个小缸里头，蒯上一勺猪油，大铁锅里这样一弄开。
[主播] 那是因为你才刚开始看。
[主播] 你看看就好了。
[主播] 说明你还是累。
[主播] 从鸡窝里摸俩鸡蛋，啪啪一打进去。
[主播] 你好好休息一段时间，你身体彻底不累了。
[主播] 哇，这天呐。
[主播] 你读书速度就快了。
[主播] 怎么有那么好吃的东西。
[嘉宾] 还有2000单卖完，然后差不多那个那本就好了。
[主播] 只剩2000单了是吧？
[主播] 长大之后家里不养猪了。
[主播] 那盘这个是。
[主播] 然后那个黑猪的品种也越来越少了的。
[主播] 现在大家养的都是白猪，因为白猪生长速度快嘛，四个月就出栏了。
[主播] 188,然后四斤肉，再加上一斤的五花肉，所以总共五斤对吧？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 黑猪188五斤。
[主播] 那还行。
[嘉宾] 是我们的产品。
[主播] 当然大家可能会觉得说，那个不健康啥，有可能有可能。
[主播] 但是小时候没考虑那么多。
[主播] 五公海产品啊。
[主播] 好吃是真好吃。
[主播] 黑猪的话就还行。
[主播] 你现在去很多的大家去我们的饮食文化里头，你发现钻了很多的小巷子，去找那家老店。
[主播] 因为正常情况黑猪的价格应该在大部分啊，应该在白猪的。
[主播] 四倍左右，啊。
[主播] 环境都不一定好，就是味道好，对吧。
[主播] 四四倍左右，甚至夸张到五倍都是很正常的。
[主播] 味道好，你说它跟我们所说的这个营养或者是安全性来说，确实很多时候没有办法共存。
[主播] 因为。
[主播] 给大家讲过一个这个背后的知识。
[主播] 但是偶尔吃，没啥事，对吧，你又不是每天大量吃。
[主播] 我们现在所吃的白猪是我们本土的猪吗？
[主播] 不谈计量谈效果，那是胡说八道。
[主播] 不是。
[主播] 我不知道你们小时候吃过那个，那个是真好吃。
[主播] 刚到手是脆的，但是放几天软了之后，其实就是再软和脆之间那一段更好吃。
[主播] 彻底软了也不好吃了。
[主播] 炒椒房门可以。
[主播] 好。
[主播] 我们黑猪肋排给大家加了库存了，加了。
[主播] 300多单。
[主播] 黑猪肋排加了300多单是吧？
[主播] 大家说董宇辉一直摸鼻子。
[主播] 我不知道为什么，每次因为前面必须得有光，没有光的话，我脸是黑的，大家看不清我。
[主播] 但是一有光，我眼睛和鼻子就开始痒。
[主播] 毛病比较多吧，嗯。
[主播] 丑人多作怪嘛，大家理解一下哈。
[主播] 我尽量不摸了。
[主播] 白猪更多是英国和美国进口的猪。
[主播] 能理解吧？
[主播] 这些猪的一个特点是什么，大概四个月就能出栏。
[主播] 有朋友说董宇辉终于给自己找到新的借口了，对光过敏。
[主播] 你知道这些猪长得快，吃饲料一天长好几斤呢。
[主播] 但是我们本土的猪其实是黑猪。
[主播] 昨天是对中关村的空气过敏，让俞老师去云南把我带着。
[主播] 就是脸皱在一起那种猪。
[主播] 今天是直播间里的光过敏。
[主播] 它生长时间很慢，一般情况下得需要300天左右。
[主播] 我应该去大兴安岭的深处。
[主播] 甚至时间更夸张。
[主播] 小时候你家里在农村生活的话，你记得过完年就买那个小猪仔回来，对吧？
[主播] 清晨的第一缕阳光，洒在了露珠上。
[主播] 一直养到第二年腊月才杀才宰杀呢。
[主播] 反射出一种彩色的细碎的犹如迷虹一样的光。
[主播] 腊月中旬才宰杀呢。
[主播] 所以生长时间长，那你再想一想，比如说养白猪我一年可以卖四次钱。
[主播] 那个光应该会不舒服，应该应该不存在不舒服的情况吧。
[主播] 我就可以薄利多销。
[其他] 应该会。
[主播] 但是白黑猪一年只能出一栏啊。
[主播] 你懂我意思吗？
[主播] 所以它确实价格就要高一些了。
[主播] 啊，不要脸，为了不上班，啥话都说得出来。
[主播] 在营养性上来说，坦诚来说没有太大区别。
[主播] 没有太大区别。
[主播] 因为吃的都是蛋白质嘛。
[主播] 脂肪嘛。
[主播] 来，我现在的声音正常了没？
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 我现在的声音正常不？
[主播] 但是口感上差异非常大。
[其他] 有人说董宇辉矫情。
[主播] 你是真的能吃出来的。
[主播] 这不叫矫情，这叫心机。
[主播] 因为黑猪生长时间长，所以它能嚼的一种胶质感。
[主播] 心机不轨说的就是我这种孩子。
[主播] 你看小时候吃肉香啊。
[主播] 有很多朋友问董宇辉为什么每天这个总是感觉苦大仇深的，然后眉头皱着。
[主播] 第二个黑猪相对肥，所以煮出来那个汤。
[主播] 香味浓。
[嘉宾] 那它煮的是不是时间也要长一些？
[主播] 哎，对，煮的时间长，因为它肉老嘛。
[主播] 晚上睡不着觉呢，翻来覆去呢。
[主播] 然后第三个就是特点是什么？
[主播] 优思过度啊。
[主播] 翻译成白话文，就是心机不轨。
[主播] 声音正常吧，导演？
[主播] 正常啊。
[主播] 来，今天给大家再来两本书。
[主播] 好，两本书，非常好的两本书，叫做长江和黄河。
[主播] 我觉得镜头前的家人们，我的意思家长们，应该给自己的孩子们。
[主播] 去买这两本书。
[主播] 长江和黄河这两本书啊，刚才我是不是说如果今天抽中的话，我们要给大家送一些东西啊。
[主播] 来，大家准备好了没？准备好了请回复准备好了，我接下来提问了啊。
[其他] 一箱是吧？
[主播] 一箱。
[其他] OK。
[主播] 哎，那我可不可以抽两次，一次一箱，我抽两次。
[主播] 也可以是吧？
[其他] 你现在你现在都开始提问我们了，还问我们。
[主播] 导演已经。
[主播] 嗯，行，好好好，谢谢谢谢谢谢。
[主播] 就是黑猪肉，生长时间长，我给大家讲一下，它古氨酸氨基酸等等这一类含量可能古氨酸含量吧，尤其是相对高一些。
[主播] 第一个。
[主播] 准备好了，回复准备好了啊。
[主播] 所以鲜啊。
[主播] 我提问了啊。
[主播] 我一会在这看到的第一个正确答案，我就读他的名字，好吧。
[主播] 就是我们说喝的汤里头的鲜味。
[其他] 好。
[主播] 应该把这个给大家煮成一碗排骨汤上上来。
[主播] 我就送了啊。
[主播] 瞬间就饿了，我告诉你。
[主播] 这样我还能忍饥吃一点。
[主播] 第一个啊。
[主播] 啊。
[嘉宾] 晚上。
[嘉宾] 还有1000单。
[主播] 黄河长度是多少？
[主播] 只剩1000单了是吧？
[主播] 不要查，不许查。
[主播] 不许查，我在这等着啊。
[主播] 但这个排骨它修得很精致啊。
[主播] 他把上面的肥油应该都去掉了。
[主播] 黄河6300，错了，6300多。
[主播] 准确数字，不要说5400多。
[主播] 正常的黑猪那肥油特别厚，我记得小时候我们家养的黑猪那肥油真的是。
[主播] 准确数字。
[主播] 准确数字，到现在没有一个对的啊。
[主播] 夸张的一指头厚的肥油。
[其他] 那个。
[主播] 我不知道大家小时候养过那个黑猪没？
[主播] 5400多，那是不准确，不准确，有准确数字。
[主播] 一指头厚的那个肥油。
[主播] 到现在没有一个人说准确的啊。
[主播] 然后呢。
[主播] 到现在都没有。
[主播] 皮下脂肪，还有。
[主播] 到现在还没有。
[主播] 这个它肚子内脏旁边的脂肪。
[主播] 我记得小时候家里养那个黑猪，每次宰杀完了之后。
[主播] 奶奶就会很耐心的把那个肥油往摘下来。
[主播] 哎，咱干嘛呢？
[主播] 我跟你说，导演你在这找一找，找到5464你就说他名字就行。
[主播] 然后呢放一个锅里头，先是用水在那煮。
[其他] 直接说出来。
[主播] 你们你们家弄过没？
[主播] 切成小块煮。
[主播] 有5464吗？
[主播] 5465也算。
[主播] 煮着煮着最后把那个水就全部蒸发掉了，因为水会蒸发，但油不会蒸发。
[其他] 也算。
[主播] 谁？
[主播] 蒸发掉了之后，那个颜色就越来越金亮，越来越金亮。
[主播] 快，读一个名字，快。
[其他] 萨拉拉。
[主播] 然后那个白色的脂肪块就变成了像炸干的那个东西一样。
[主播] 萨拉拉是吧？
[其他] 对。
[主播] 好，恭喜你，萨拉拉。
[主播] 我要送你一箱野生蓝莓原浆了啊。
[主播] 6300多，那是长江的长度。
[主播] 黄河的准确的记录的长度是5464啊。
[主播] 一会还有机会。
[主播] 你看。
[主播] 非要告诉孩子们知道这些不用的知识，有一天也能帮你赢点小礼品。
[主播] 就像我整天说我妈，我说妈，你去参加那些给你们干啥的，一早上在那开会。
[主播] 我妈说谁说没用，我今天回来领了四个鸡蛋呢。
[主播] 大概就是那个意思，啊。
[主播] 接下来给大家讲一讲这两本书啊。
[主播] 我一会还会再提问。
[主播] 仔细等着。
[主播] 有朋友说我是第一个，我刚刚说的，对不起啊，对不起。
[主播] 我只能说我看见的第一个，因为大家发的屏幕信息跟这我显示的，不一样，不对称，这个确实不对称。
[主播] 一直嚼着嚼着。
[其他] 有点太快。
[主播] 最后就炼出了一缸油。
[主播] 对，因为大家现在直播间里有22万人，然后呢，不可能显示22万人所有的啊。
[主播] 然后家里是有一个小小的那个水缸。
[主播] 确实不一定真实啊，大家这个一箱蓝莓原浆呢，不是重点，咱重在参与。
[主播] 小缸。
[主播] 司马光砸缸嘛。
[主播] 重点是通过这个过程呢，希望能够给大家这个。
[主播] 那种小的缸。
[主播] 陕西人把那个叫瓮，瓮中捉鳖的瓮嘛。
[主播] 其实很多地方也说瓮的啊。
[主播] 小的缸或者小的瓮里头。
[主播] 给大家呼吁一些阅读的过程，好吧，嗯。
[主播] 然后呢一直这个煎这个在锅里头炸到最后，它已经水分彻底蒸发完了之后。
[主播] 那个。
[主播] 我天，那个油的香味飘得到处都是，你在院子里都能闻到那个香味。
[主播] 那个那个叫做锦上添花呀。
[主播] 那个不重要，不重要啊。
[主播] 继续啊。
[主播] 你看现在评论区已经，至少有几千个人跟我说，我才是第一个。
[主播] 那你们几千个人到底谁是第一个？
[主播] 所以我刚才说了，我读的第一个就是第一个，好吧，嗯。
[主播] 不不不客许，不准确啊。
[主播] 今天给大家讲长江和黄河这俩个，这两本书啊。
[主播] 长江一共流经了多少个省份啊，朋友们？
[主播] 长江流过了多少个省份？
[主播] 有没有跟长江或者黄河相关的音乐？
[其他] 答对了可以。
[其他] 这是第二个问题吗？
[主播] 这不是第二个问题，这个现在在在那个。
[其他] 有人说23个。
[主播] 胡说，长江和黄河流过多少个城市？
[主播] 11个啊，11个。
[主播] 11个。
[主播] 然后呢，你可以以后带着孩子，你看我之前给大家推荐过几个线路。
[主播] 第一个，真的时间多的话，开车带着孩子，长江基本上是个V，对吧，黄河呢是个几字型。
[主播] 沿着长江走一圈，沿着黄河走一圈。
[主播] 然后再接下来呢，就是沿着京杭大运河走一圈。
[主播] 还有呢，沿着丝绸之路走一圈。
[主播] 我的天呐。
[主播] 全是历史，全是故事，全是文明。
[主播] 长江流过11个城市。
[主播] 来，我们之前给大家讲过，世界上有四大文明。
[主播] 这两本书，我先给大家展示书里头都有什么啊，你看。
[主播] 首先，黄河。
[主播] 这是中华民族的母亲河，The Cradle of Our Civilization。
[主播] 我给大家讲那个英语怎么写啊。
[主播] 你看。
[主播] 这个书页可以展开的，它有一个非常完整的地形图。
[主播] 我的天呐。
[主播] 看到没？
[主播] 它告诉你黄河从哪里发源。
[主播] 黄河之水天上来，奔流到海不复回，高堂明镜悲白发，朝如青丝暮成雪。
[主播] 但实际上呢，黄河这水不是天上来，黄河之水是在青海发源的啊。
[主播] 三江源嘛，大家应该初中地理都学过了。
[主播] 然后呢，这样合住呢，它是给你一个这样的路线图，看到了没？
[主播] 黄河流经的地方，然后最后从山东入了海啊。
[主播] 然后它还给你分这个纵截面的阶梯。
[主播] 大家都知道这个黄河的这个河，叫什么，河堤，黄河的河堤流经开封的时候，比开封塔塔顶要高七米。
[主播] 所以你知道为什么历史上河南多灾多难吗？
[其他] 就是地势低。
[主播] 就是绝地。
[主播] 大家记得一幅画吧，叫做清明上河图记得不？
[其他] 记得。
[主播] 画的就是汴梁。
[主播] 但是那个风景大家已经看不到了，因为黄河历史上多次绝地，已经把他们都埋到地下去了。
[主播] 你懂我的意思吧？
[主播] 河南多灾多难呢，历史上。
[主播] 所以，我每次见到河南朋友会特别亲切，我觉得真的是受过苦的，啊。
[主播] 但是你看黄河在宁夏那一代，在河套平原那一代，那可真的是非常的富裕。
[主播] 当然我们也理性的承认，比如说黄河的绝地经常会带来灾难，但是之前也给大家讲过，就是每次冲击之后留下肥沃的土壤，会给大家留下更多的种植的地方。
[主播] 但是它这个绝地不定期，这个确实就让人很难受的，让人很难受。
[主播] 我关系好的几个朋友都是河南的。
[主播] 就是因为我很小很小的时候，我们家不是离河南特别近嘛，过了潼关就是河南，我爸小时候跟我讲了很多次，比如说以前小时候经常就有河南一些一些同胞们，他们来我们那块。
[主播] 每次来了之后，就是特别苦难，拉着自己的孩子，你我小时候还有过那种事，你想就是家里比如说离黄河近的。
[主播] 发一次大水，什么都冲走了，然后一般人来了之后，就把他带到奶奶家，奶奶就给做饭吃，在家里住一段时间。
[主播] 然后最后修养好了，那些人就送他们走。
[主播] 我记得有一次那个人在我们家待了很久很久，我送那个人走的时候，我哭了，我都难受，因为我跟那个小孩玩得特别开心。
[主播] 所以我后来一见他们就特别亲切，特别亲切。
[主播] 就是他们有种特别天然的这种亲切，朴实。
[主播] 很热心，特别热心。
[其他] 而且很勤奋。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 你昨天看跟我一块跳这个腾格尔那个舞，对吧？
[主播] 那是河南周口的。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 就是我关系最好的朋友了。
[主播] 然后接下来你看它这里有完整的给你讲这个黄河的上游。
[主播] 它是按照黄河的顺序继续给你往后在讲，看到了没？
[主播] 中华水塔，三江源。
[主播] 然后呢，唐古拉山口。
[主播] 当然你要去自驾的话，你走青藏这个路，走川藏的话，太险了，走青藏你是能够看到藏羚羊的。
[主播] 藏羚羊全速奔跑起来，在那个路面上可比车跑得快，你知道吧？
[主播] 藏羚羊能跑80、90公里每小时的。
[主播] 非常快的速度。
[主播] 因为我是看过一个关于藏羚羊的纪录片的。
[主播] 这回应该都有藏羚羊的。
[主播] 看它是从第一阶梯，第二阶梯，第三阶梯，然后整个的纵截面给你画下来的，啊。
[主播] 你看黄河沿路的城市，大家能看到这里。
[主播] 西宁当然离黄河比较远，兰州。
[主播] 兰州兰州，哎，你能放一个低苦艾那个兰州兰州没？
[其他] 兰州。
[主播] 你走的时候没有带走玫瑰花，兰州兰州。
[主播] 美猴王的画像。
[主播] 白塔嘛。
[主播] 然后我每次去兰州的时候，你感觉一个很纵深的这个峡谷里头，然后呢，人们很早前，你知道兰州人不把那个叫。
[主播] 这个拉面。
[主播] 兰州把那个叫牛肉面。
[其他] 牛肉面。
[主播] 而且兰州牛肉面是当早餐吃的。
[主播] 12点以后就没了。
[主播] 然后一大早去吃一碗热热的那个面，我的天呐，真好吃。
[主播] 你知道有一年我开车就是经过了兰州。
[主播] 我在这停下来，然后就吃了个这个。
[主播] 一大早睡醒之后。
[其他] 睡醒之后。
[主播] 你声音放大点，我听一下。
[其他] 低苦艾乐队。
[其他] 是这个地方。
[主播] 啊，对对对对，谢谢，谢谢导演。
[主播] 我特别喜欢兰州。
[主播] 我喜欢兰州一大早煮的那一锅，然后咕嘟咕嘟冒着热气，那个牛肉面的汤。
[主播] 然后呢，你进去就老板，二细，辣子多写。
[主播] 一定注意要这样说，一定得这样说，这样说才地道。
[主播] 二细。
[主播] 二细是什么意思呢？
[主播] 二细大概就是像筷子头这么粗的。
[主播] 比这能再细一点点吧。
[主播] 二细。
[主播] 就是它它不是有九叶宽，毛细，二细。
[主播] 还有细的。
[主播] 就是西北话都一样，陕西话也。
[主播] 得得。
[主播] 细的面，就细的。
[主播] 细的。
[主播] 二细，毛细。
[主播] 然后辣子多写。
[主播] 注意他们的辣子跟西安的辣子不一样。
[主播] 哎呀。
[主播] 它重点不是辣。
[主播] 它就是香啊。
[主播] 香到气人，你知道吗？
[主播] 老板，二细，辣子多写，啊。
[主播] 然后呢就给你弄一碗，那个汤喝着特别香浓。
[主播] 然后那个调料的混合呀，哎呀。
[主播] 美到气人。
[主播] 然后他们还有一个喝的东西，你其实在西安也能喝到，牛奶，醪糟，鸡蛋。
[主播] 喝过没？
[主播] 我是2020年的5月1号，应该是前天晚上开到那块。
[主播] 我晚上刮大风，下一场雨，第二天早上起来全身的泥点子，车窗都呼掩饰了。
[主播] 那就是那里的地理环境。
[主播] 你想就是那样的千年吹过的风啊，然后呢，降水量很少，但是蒸发量很大，全部都是那个灰尘。
[主播] 我但是有很多学生在兰州大学读书。
[主播] 学医的。
[主播] 学临床的好像是。
[主播] 然后呢，我特别喜欢兰州。
[主播] 就是每次你站在那样的地方，你看着奔腾的黄河水，你想象这里诉说过多少不为人知的故事。
[主播] 然后你再接着这首歌，这首歌还在放，对吧？
[主播] 继续放。
[主播] 兰州兰州，啊。
[主播] 总是在清晨里出走，因为一大早起来赶那碗滚烫的牛肉面，哎呀。
[主播] 你看，我跟你说要开着车带孩子走这一圈。
[主播] 真的值得。
[其他] 是不是下雨不好？
[主播] 兰州。
[主播] 然后兰州过来这块大城市叫啥？银川，你看这叫宁夏平原。
[主播] 其实就是我们所说的西套平原，宁夏嘛。
[主播] 然后宁夏平原有什么？好的西瓜，对吧，好的蜜瓜，好的枸杞，啊。
[主播] 然后呢，再接下来你到这块河套平原，它就分前套和后套的。
[主播] 然后大家看，正常按照纬度其实从这一直往北冲去了，对吧？
[主播] 如果按着往北冲去，那黄河就不会孕育后来的后面这些文明的关中平原啊，就是我的老家，你像西安，十三朝古都。
[主播] 以及下游的这个收养后的河南，和更下游的这个山东的。
[主播] 那为什么黄河在这没有继续向北流去呢？各位朋友，我们得感谢一个山。
[主播] 阴山山脉。
[主播] 大家记得之前给大家讲过叫敕勒歌吧？
[主播] 记得不？
[其他] 记得。
[主播] 敕勒歌第一句话是什么？
[其他] 敕勒歌阴山下。
[主播] 阴山下。
[主播] 然后呢？
[其他] 天似穹庐。
[主播] 什么呢？还有还有呢？
[其他] 笼盖四野。
[主播] 笼盖四野，紧接下来。
[其他] 天苍苍。
[主播] 天苍苍，野茫茫，然后呢？
[其他] 风吹草地现牛羊。
[主播] 现牛羊。
[主播] 所以敕勒川嘛，对吧，大家都知道。
[主播] 就是因为在这里有这个阴山的阻挡，所以它水没有继续向北流去。
[主播] 你想如果没阴山的话，这就一直流到内蒙，流到更北去了。
[主播] 真的流到俄罗斯去了就有可能。
[主播] 那就没有中华文明了。
[主播] 感谢阴山吧。
[主播] 感谢阴山，真的感谢阴山。
[主播] 但是你看它这块有很多的这个冲积的平原，所以以前我们古代的时候不是很担心嘛，匈奴来犯嘛，对吧，所以这个秦始皇从从咸阳这，一路修直道，一直修到这。
[主播] 800里嘛，修直道修到了阴山这里，修到了其实现在是应该是现在内蒙的这个包头。
[主播] 石底包头。
[主播] 然后接下来这块就是银川。
[主播] 银川也是好地方啊。
[主播] 我特别爱银川，我把银川都去过五次还是六次了。
[主播] 从西安一路开车过去，穿过各种隧道隧道隧道，一路都是隧道，限速60。
[主播] 但是你反而就放松下，你不起，为什么急着赶着目的地呢？
[主播] 因为目的地终于会到的。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 然后呢，这银川。
[主播] 然后接下来大家也能看到了这个，当然也有朋友去很多说包头。
[主播] 包头。
[主播] 呼和浩特。
[主播] 再接下来你从这块到了这个龙门。
[主播] 到下面就叫做风陵渡。
[主播] 风陵渡口初相遇，一见杨过误终身。
[主播] 你看风陵渡这个角，华山这个角看到了没？
[主播] 董宇辉他我就是在这。
[主播] 家人们。
[主播] 董宇辉他我就是这个潼关，潼关的这个黄河拐弯这，风陵渡就在潼关，陕西的风景。
[主播] 你看这边是陕西，这边是山西，这边是河南。
[主播] 到了河南，到了郑州。
[主播] 当然到了郑州，大家知道这个后来修的这个三门峡大坝。
[主播] 我小的时候呢，三门峡大坝这个泥沙淤积非常严重，每年一到秋天一下秋雨，这个水一路从河南涨上来，涨到渭河谷地。
[主播] 像咱前两天卖过大路大力的冬枣，记得吧？
[主播] 那全部都会淹在水里头，黄河水一路涨上来。
[主播] 但是后来已经通过有效的方法把那个泥沙堆积的问题解决了。
[主播] 也在适当的时候泄洪，所以现在后来再没有遇见过了。
[主播] 嗯，黄河。
[主播] 因为当时苏联人在修的时候，其实是没有在这种泥沙比较多的水河上修过大坝的经验的。
[主播] 当时也算是前无古人，坦诚来说。
[主播] 因为苏联他们的河流主要都是比比泥沙量含量比较小的河流嘛。
[主播] 然后过了郑州，接下来就是济南。
[主播] 从济南这里之后就入海了。
[主播] 这是黄河一个大概的，我这说的非常的这个粗略啊，很多黄河边的小城市我们都没有给大家提到。
[主播] 从齐南这里之后就入海了。
[主播] 强硬魁梧的身躯拦住了滚滚东进黄河，迫使黄河沿着低洼流淌，这就是著名的晋陕大峡谷啊。
[主播] 当然呢，这个黄河也有特别狭窄的地方。
[主播] 窄在哪呢？窄到大家所知道的这个黄河。
[主播] 我们刚刚还说，黄河还流过哪？流过宁夏对吧？
[嘉宾] 宁夏。
[主播] 我们放那个宁静的夏天，天空中繁星点点。
[主播] 好吗？
[主播] 黄河特别窄的地方就是大家所知道的壶口瀑布了。
[嘉宾] 壶口瀑布。
[主播] 虎跳峡怎么能在黄河胡说？
[主播] 虎跳峡不在黄河呀，朋友们。
[主播] 就是壶口瀑布嘛。
[主播] 壶口瀑布的那边是山西，壶口瀑布的这边是陕西。
[主播] 我在2020年吧，冬天，寒冬腊月啊，我去过一次，零下20多度，冻的呀，我的天。
[主播] 然后上面结了一层厚厚的冰。
[主播] 但是冰下面水还是在流动。
[主播] 我当时应该是去山西极县，山西极县的那个高中，还去做过一次演讲。
[主播] 当时不是全国有那种公益讲座吗？
[主播] 那块的老师联系我们。
[主播] 看。
[主播] 天下黄河富宁夏。
[主播] 宁夏不仅有好的枸杞。
[主播] 这是黄河一个大概的，我这说的非常的这个粗略啊，很多黄河边的小城市，我们都没有给大家提到。
[主播] 好的小麦。
[主播] 好的羊。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 好的瓜。
[主播] 宁夏还有好的风景啊，塞上江南啊，朋友们。
[嘉宾] 今天给大家选了宁夏的盐池滩羊。
[主播] 盐池滩羊有是吧？
[嘉宾] 三号链接。
[主播] 三号链接有盐池滩羊。
[主播] 然后黄河啊。
[主播] 这个是黄河，导演你先对。
[主播] 让我看一下黄河这个这个部分的那个价格。
[主播] 这两本书的价格。
[嘉宾] 这两本书一共是79。
[主播] 一共79啊，好好好。
[主播] 一共79。
[主播] 想的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 黄河一共流经了多少个省份啊？
[主播] 我们刚问了长江啊。
[主播] 黄河是多少个省份？
[主播] 虎跳峡在云南呢。
[主播] 虎跳峡在云南什么地方呢？
[主播] 丽江，离丽江不远。
[主播] 因为我是当年去跟我们的，我在当年在西安高中那的时候去带老师们去丽江玩一次。
[主播] 团建。
[主播] 怎么能叫玩呢？工作怎么能玩这么说呢？
[主播] 然后呢，爬过玉龙雪山，去过虎跳峡。
[主播] 因为据说那就是陆地上这个最深的流的点了。
[主播] 然后山底有个大石头嘛。
[主播] 为什么叫虎跳峡呢？
[主播] 据说当年有个白虎跳了那个石头从河那边跳到了河这边。
[主播] 所以叫虎跳峡。
[主播] 然后呢，我们刚给大家讲过了，这个一般情况下。
[主播] 因为中国的地形分三个阶梯嘛。
[主播] 这三个阶梯分别是怎么体现的？来大家看这啊。
[主播] 这三个阶梯分别这样子，你看。
[主播] 黄色的这就是一级阶梯，看到了没？
[主播] 这就是挤压之后直接形成凸起的这个青藏高原。
[主播] 然后白色的这些一般叫做二级阶梯，主要是以一些，比如说蒙古高原、黄土高原、云贵高原等等，这些为主。
[主播] 还有一些山脉。
[主播] 然后下面绿色部分叫三级阶梯。
[主播] 那一般情况下我们的水电站都在哪里修呢？
[嘉宾] 阶梯之间。
[主播] 一般是这个一二级阶梯，或者是二三级阶梯之间。
[主播] 为什么在阶梯上修呢？因为这个时候落差大。
[主播] 水的势能比较足，非常好。
[主播] 水流湍急，所以才能带动着那些东西。
[主播] 能理解吧？
[主播] OK。
[主播] 这就是这个水电站的部分，刚才给大家讲到了黄河。
[主播] 三门峡当年修成之后，一年左右水库就淤积了，说有16亿吨的黄沙。
[主播] 我们老家的潼关，潼关一路就水一路从河南就漫上来了。
[主播] 但是后来我们已经解决了这个泥沙的问题。
[主播] 但其实水电站这个就是水电站当然在造福，但是大家水电站后期的很多的问题也必须得持续的关注。
[主播] 如果说你看你给孩子讲这个，孩子最后对水电站产生了兴趣，让孩子不断去研究这个。
[主播] 因为你要知道历史上所修建的第一个水电站，到现在还没有到它的使用寿命呢。
[主播] 水电站一般的使用寿命是多少年？
[主播] 多少年？
[主播] 之前在20世纪修的大部分是100到150年。
[主播] 后来修的部分水电站能够设计到200年左右的寿命。
[主播] 你你算一下，那从1920年修水电站到现在是不是它寿命快到了？
[主播] 快到了吧？
[主播] 哎，水电站到寿命之后这个怎么解决？
[主播] 这个问题其实很严重的。
[主播] 现在设计的大部分都是200年的这个使用寿命。
[主播] 但是你知道美国不是当年修过那个胡佛水坝吗？
[主播] 知道吧？
[主播] 它是不是拱形的那个吗？
[主播] 你看变形金刚四里头，就是那个霸天虎就在里头被拆解的那个地方，你看过没？
[主播] 看过。
[主播] 就是那个胡佛水坝嘛。
[主播] 弯的那个。
[主播] 它那里面特别大的那个水坝。
[主播] 它为什么不修直的呢？因为直的没有办法，水势能太大，把那个会压垮的。
[主播] 它只能修个弯的。
[嘉宾] 只剩1000本了。
[主播] 只剩1000本了，是吧？
[主播] 对对对，这个黄河流经的九个省份啊。
[主播] 感谢感谢有朋友在评论区替我们回答了。
[主播] 你看黄河一路过来的文明。
[主播] 我们说黄河叫文明，是我们文明的摇篮啊，对吧？The cradle of our civilization。
[主播] 然后流经的黄河，你看在这里，这里就是潼关。
[主播] 到了潼关就有什么呀？潼关入家魔。
[主播] 因为是正好是天险嘛。
[主播] 所以在这里头，我们给大家曾经讲过很多关于潼关的故事，潼关的史诗剧。
[主播] 潼关入家魔在几号链接？
[嘉宾] 潼关入家魔，我们放到三号链接。
[主播] 放到三号链接，想的朋友去拍啊。
[主播] 来几个小知识，刚才第一个讲了长江流经了11个省份。
[主播] 黄河流经了九个啊。
[主播] 九个省份。
[主播] 这第一个。
[主播] 第二个，分别的长度是多少？
[主播] 长度是多少？
[主播] 我们之前所说的这个黄河的长度叫5464啊，很多是这样说的。
[主播] 5464。
[主播] 然后长江是多少？
[主播] 长江是6396或者6397啊，但是我看到的一个比较用的多的是6396这个数字。
[主播] 这个是长江的长度。
[主播] 这个是黄河的长度。
[主播] 长江的长度是世界第几长？
[嘉宾] 第三。
[主播] 第三长。
[主播] 它次于这个Nile and Amazon。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 长江是这个。
[主播] 对，世界第三长啊。
[主播] 当然我也给大家说注意，就是关于这个数字可能你们是看过很多个不同版本的，大家能理解吧？
[主播] 可能是看过不同版本，有6396的，有6397的。
[主播] 甚至还有其他的数字，但是到了后来很多人就说大概是6300左右。
[主播] 因为大家知道有说你计算的，你看你计算的这个点在哪，你稍微把这个计算的点偏左偏右一点点，可能几十米的差距就出去了。
[主播] OK。
[主播] 世界第三。
[主播] 第三长度。
[主播] 分别在前面的是Niles and Amazon，Nile是尼罗河和亚马逊河流啊。
[主播] 然后呢，这是第二长度。
[主播] 第三个我们讲到了，说。
[主播] 黄河是什么呢？黄河是文明的摇篮，对不对？
[主播] 摇篮怎么说？叫做the cradle。
[主播] Cradle。
[主播] Cradle就是摇篮。
[主播] The cradle of our our什么呀？
[主播] Our civilization。
[主播] Civilization就是文明。
[主播] 文明和文化不一样。
[主播] 文化什么？文化是语言，是文字，是戏曲，是建筑。
[主播] 文明是什么？文明是一个人群的修养生息。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 来，想的朋友自己去拍了啊。
[主播] 我卖货呢，我在卖这两本书啊。
[主播] 我刚跟你说的，你应该把这两本书一块拍了，让孩子带回去。
[主播] 让孩子带回去，然后呢，跟孩子一块去沿着黄河走一圈，沿着长江走一圈，然后沿着丝绸之路走一圈，沿着京杭大运河走一圈。
[主播] 就是你沿着这些走，一路上那种人文、历史、美景、美食，多丰富的体验，你说去那不比钻到景点有意思多了。
[主播] 我就是不喜欢去景点。
[主播] 我一般去都是挑人少的时候去，或者正好我就喜欢走那种没有特殊景点，但是很有历史厚重感的地方。
[主播] 你要是真的带着孩子走一趟黄河啊，你会发现美啊，真美啊。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 嗓子有点，我喝口水，嗓子有点痒。
[主播] 好。
[主播] 有朋友说董老师是有鼻炎吧，也不是，我不知道为什么，反正就是鼻子竟然会痒。
[主播] 那说到长江了，我问一下大家，这个长江的第一大支流是哪？
[主播] 问一下大家。
[主播] 问一下大家，哎呀。
[主播] 汉江是这个。
[主播] 长度第一啊。
[主播] 但是如果说水量第一的话，应该叫做嘉陵江。
[主播] 嘉陵江，不是怒江，嘉陵江。
[主播] 有朋友说杨子江。
[主播] 杨子江就是长江。
[主播] 说的是啥？
[主播] 沱沱河。
[主播] 沱沱河是长江的上游叫沱沱河。
[主播] 啊不是不是什么长江。
[主播] 沱沱河是它的上游。
[主播] 嘉陵江，嘉陵江啊。
[主播] 有朋友说组织个夏令营，其实挺好的。
[主播] 组织个一些学生，然后我们沿着黄河走一趟，沿着长江走一趟，沿着丝绸走了，一趟。
[主播] 一路给孩子讲。
[主播] 太有意思了。
[主播] 汉江是长度啊。
[主播] 但是它不是水量，水量大的第一应该是嘉陵江。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 这里也讲到岷江。
[主播] 其实长江的这个支流是有一个口诀的，我给你找这头估计应该是有得。
[主播] 你记住八个字就行了。
[主播] 哎，有，你看啊。
[主播] 这个在大家这个一号链接去拍啊。
[主播] 这是长江的八大支流。
[主播] 大家怎么去记呢？你看。
[主播] 牙、岷、嘉、乌、汉、沅、湘、赣。
[主播] 你就记住这几个字，八个字就行了。
[主播] 长江的八大支流。
[主播] 当然你要说小支流那很多了。
[主播] 按着水流量来说，第一大的其实确实应该是嘉陵江啊。
[主播] 长江第一湾在哪啊？
[主播] 这个简单，长江第一湾在哪？
[主播] 问大家。
[主播] 母亲河呀。
[主播] 你都记不住。
[主播] 第一湾在金沙江啊。
[主播] 金沙江，金沙江在哪啊？
[主播] 在云南。
[主播] 离金沙江很近的一个地方就是哪啊？
[主播] 丽江。
[主播] 丽江古城。
[主播] 你看这还给你讲都江堰呢。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 为什么都江堰可以用2000年呢？大家知道不？
[主播] 因为这就是它的设计智慧了。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 父子俩他们曾经在设计的时候。
[主播] 他们在设计这块的时候，当年因为没有大的这种炸药的爆破。
[主播] 也没有大型的挖掘机的这个设备去挖。
[主播] 所以当年是怎么把那个山开个口呢？
[主播] 就是把那个松油浇上去，烧。
[主播] 把石头烧得很热的时候，凉水一泼，热胀冷缩，这样硬把那块山给烧开的。
[主播] 所以它不会存在说炸药轰轰一炸，或者大型机械把旁边的山体也弄松动的原因，能理解吧？
[主播] 所以旁边的岩石没有被破坏，仍然很结实。
[主播] 你看笨办法是不是聪明办法？
[主播] 笨办法才是聪明办法呢。
[主播] 只有一个连续服务了2000年的这个水利工程，就是都江堰。
[主播] 当年在深，深移的时候，这个都江堰上面还修了一些这个索道呀什么的呢。
[主播] 把它全部都拆了。
[主播] 拆了才能，你要是上面有人工做东西就不能深了。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 然后你尤其到宝瓶口那块，它这个大的时候就把那个大的水，脏的水和大的石头就甩到外江去了。
[主播] 水小的时候就从内江流到了成都平原。
[主播] 2000年来，为什么叫天府之国呢？
[主播] 就是因为这个水利工程，所以你知道水利工程修好的真太牛了。
[主播] 你说这有没有拦的大坝？没有。
[主播] 有没有特别高深的这个设计，这个难度？
[主播] 对吧？其实大家都能，普通人都能看得懂。
[主播] 但就是你想不到啊。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 想的朋友自己去拍。
[主播] 岷江。
[主播] 四姑娘山。
[主播] 这都是在四川的啊。
[主播] 加到长江三峡，宜昌，秭归。
[主播] 你看到了，这又提到了这个。
[主播] 之前给大家说过这个秭归这个地方。
[主播] 秭归是谁的？
[主播] 这个子通子，这个子。
[主播] 就是我们说姐妹们，就是姐妹们的意思。
[主播] 我们以前老话叫子，不叫姐，姐妹们。
[主播] 秭归是谁的姐姐归来的？是屈原的姐姐。
[主播] 听闻屈原被放逐归来了。
[主播] 在湖北呢啊。
[主播] 秭归呀。
[主播] 朝发白帝城。
[主播] 长江一路的故事非常多。
[主播] 夔州，无边落木萧萧下，不尽长江滚滚来啊。
[主播] 夔州就是现在的这个重庆附近。
[主播] 夔州那块就是杜甫写过登高的地方。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 朝发白帝城也是那个地方，实际上。
[主播] 刘禹锡后来也去过夔州。
[主播] 高峡出平湖，长江三峡。
[主播] 我对长江的印象其实是什么时候变深的？就是有一次我去武汉，高铁，我前走了半天了还在江上。
[主播] 你知道我我在我们老家潼关，现在那个特别高的土垣上，每逢落日，看着大江大河，长河落日圆啊。
[主播] 真宽阔呀。
[主播] 大桥。
[主播] 再有一次就是去年五一我不是开车去带我父母回一趟湖北老家吗？其实我是没有去长江。
[主播] 但是丹江口啊。
[主播] 你知道丹江口水库，南水北调嘛。
[主播] 就是从丹江口水库开始的。
[主播] 然后呢，在那水库旁边你就一路过去看到那么多多的水漫过了那些山。
[主播] 车开了几十分钟了，还在水库周围走，丹江口水库。
[主播] 然后呢，靠山吃山靠水吃水嘛。
[主播] 那个鱼特别鲜，有一种鱼只有在当地有，白色的。
[主播] 特别嫩。
[主播] 你你吃到嘴里就真的入口即化的感觉了。
[主播] 哎呀，我后来十一还专门再去了一次，就是为了尝那一口鱼，真鲜啊，真鲜啊。
[主播] 鲜的要命。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 汉江。
[主播] 为什么叫汉中呢？就是因为汉江流过，所以叫汉中啊。
[主播] 你看这，这里头能想到的东西太多了。
[主播] 其实我讲的都不是系统的，就是一些小知识，但是很有意思。
[主播] 你让孩子去了解了解这些。
[主播] 让孩子对这个大江大河流过的地方感兴趣。
[主播] 让孩子对那些人们修养生息的城市感兴趣。
[主播] 让孩子对那些穿过清晨街道的三三四季的那些生活感兴趣。
[主播] 让孩子对那些在这个城市曾经生活过的人们留下的诗词歌赋感兴趣。
[主播] 让孩子最终因为对这一切感兴趣而热爱这片土地。
[主播] 这才是好的教育。
[主播] 看啥动画片？
[主播] 动画片有这意思。
[主播] 水电站。
[主播] 当然长江这个之前因为我们过度捕捞。
[主播] 然后呢，就导致长江里头的这个鱼类资源呢。
[主播] 近乎枯竭，所以现在长江十年禁渔嘛。
[主播] 十年禁渔，不要捞。
[主播] 这个其实就很好。
[主播] 而且你看我们之前给大家卖的那个鱼老师老家江阴，那就在长江边上。
[主播] 那个啥？
[主播] 那个叫石鱼。
[主播] 那这种从海里回游回来的鱼，长江以前捞不到了。
[主播] 以至于少到什么程度？鱼老师说一个石鱼，野生的卖一万多。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 没捞不到了后来。
[主播] 现在一禁渔正好，大家也都不吃了。
[主播] 但是我们之前给大家卖的那个石鱼，他们每年是会把很多小鱼苗放生到长江里头的。
[主播] 就他们培育了很多的。
[主播] 这个长江三鲜嘛，大家知道吧？
[主播] 石鱼、刀鱼和河豚。
[主播] 他们就把很多石鱼和刀鱼的小鱼苗放回到江里去。
[主播] 你看这就是一件好事啊。
[主播] 给子孙积福呢，这都是。
[主播] 三星堆文化。
[主播] 这几天大家开始说我是兵马俑，然后宋老师是三星堆。
[主播] 这后面还给大家配了很多的这个诗啊。
[主播] 这书知道说好就好在这，你看。
[主播] 它不仅把流经的城市，主要的这个文化，主要的建筑水利工程给大家讲完。
[主播] 后面还有这么多的诗。
[主播] 朝发白帝城。
[主播] 朝发白帝城是哪？
[主播] 就是夔州附近嘛。
[主播] 朝发白帝彩云间，千里江陵一日还，两岸猿声啼不住，轻舟已过万重山。
[主播] 为什么李白这么心情愉悦呢？
[主播] 本来是要被发配的，发配路上说算了，不发配你了。
[主播] 太开心了。
[主播] 王勃。
[主播] 长江悲已至。
[主播] 万里念乡归。
[主播] 旷野，高峰晚。
[主播] 山山黄叶飞。
[主播] 望天门山。
[主播] 天门中断楚江开，这块大家都背过。
[主播] 碧水东流至此回。
[主播] 两岸青山相对出，孤帆一片日边来。
[主播] 白居易，我的天哪。
[主播] 孟浩然。
[主播] 黄鹤楼送孟浩然之广陵。
[主播] 故人西辞黄鹤楼，烟花三月下扬州。
[主播] 孤帆远影碧空尽，唯见长江天际流啊。
[主播] 你看。
[主播] 多好的，全是这。
[主播] 让孩子背背这些。
[主播] 滚滚长江东逝水，浪花淘尽英雄。
[主播] 是非成败转头空啊。
[主播] 登高，风急天高猿啸小，这个刚给大家说的在夔州写的嘛。
[主播] 夔州杜甫去夔州的时候，当地人给他那个当地的太守给他一片果园在那写。
[主播] 60多岁。
[主播] 20多岁的时候在山东写的是岱宗夫如何，齐鲁青未了。
[主播] 造化钟神秀，阴阳割昏晓。
[主播] 那多有气势啊，他爸当然在山东兖州任职呢。
[主播] 那会年轻。
[主播] 因为黄黄河歪歪扭扭曲曲拐拐的，然后但是水又流得很缓慢很平静，因为在拐弯处嘛。
[主播] 啊，因为他拐弯其实会不断侵蚀这边的土壤，所以不断会侵蚀陕西这边的土壤，然后陕西那边留下了越来越多的冲击平原了，你知道吧？
[主播] 因为他是冲这边的嘛。
[主播] 大概就是这种场景，特别的壮观。
[主播] 黄河之水天上来，奔流到海不复回啊。
[主播] 大概就是那个意思。
[主播] 右下角自己去拍啊，自己去拍。
[主播] 九曲回肠。
[主播] 黄河沟，黄土高原。
[主播] 先有黄河还是先有峡谷？
[主播] 200万年前，秦岭和阴山之间发生一次地震，然后这个山被劈成了两半，山西和陕西之间形成了低洼地带。
[主播] 吕梁山。
[主播] 戴宗夫如何，其路清为料。
[主播] 造化中神秀阴阳割昏晓。
[主播] 那多有气势啊。
[主播] 他爸当然在山东演州任职呢。
[主播] 那会年轻。
[主播] 年少不知愁啊。
[主播] 年少的时候经常像董宇辉这种矫情的，未复心思强说愁。
[主播] 你就没有苦，你非要这给他数你苦。
[主播] 胡说八道最后只能矫揉造作啊。
[主播] 到了老的时候，你看写著风急天高。
[主播] 猿啸哀。
[主播] 注意是哀啊。
[主播] 哀鸣啊，主清沙白鸟飞回。
[主播] 绝，就是千古绝篇啊，真的。
[主播] 七言在杜府的登高里头，你能够看到很很难有人比他再写的更好了。
[主播] 从风景，从环境到心理，到最后的这个精神的寄托，太完美了。
[主播] 无边落木萧萧下，给大家讲过这叫shower by shower,对吧？
[主播] 什么叫萧萧下？就像你家里洗的淋浴一样。
[主播] 一阵一阵的，像小雨一样。
[主播] 所以叫萧萧下，这本书的右下角大家赶快去拍啊。
[主播] 叫shower by shower。
[主播] 一号链接是吧？
[主播] 是的。
[主播] shower by shower。
[主播] 然后呢，不尽长江滚滚来。
[主播] 你看抽刀断水水更流啊。
[主播] 你能砍得断吗？
[主播] 砍不断的，对吧？
[主播] 一分接一分，一秒接一秒的。
[主播] 那为什么他不是分和秒呢？
[主播] 因为shower,是不是就压上运了？
[主播] 这就是学员中老师的节奏。
[主播] 学员中老师很多翻译真的是传神之笔。
[主播] 不尽长江滚滚来，万里悲秋常作客，百年多病独登台。
[主播] 艰难苦恨繁霜病，聊到心疼著酒杯啊。
[主播] 还有周言邦写的这个金陵怀古。
[主播] 这个大家少也背过。
[主播] 春江花月夜。
[主播] 大唐绝篇啊。
[主播] 春江潮水连海平，海上明月共潮生。
[主播] 然后再加还有念奴娇赤壁怀古，这是苏氏写的。
[主播] 这个大家也都知道，对吧？
[主播] 大江东去浪淘尽，千古风流人物，故垒西边人道是三国周郎赤壁。
[主播] 乱石穿空，惊涛拍岸，卷起千堆雪。
[主播] 诗词里的长江。
[主播] 然后接下来这个李之仪写的，我住长江头，君住长江尾。
[主播] 这块大家知道吧？
[主播] 日日思君不见君，共饮长江水。
[主播] 此水几时休啊？
[主播] 此恨何时已。
[主播] 只愿君心似我心，定不负相思意。
[主播] 明明来了。
[主播] 大家要等明明来了。
[主播] 多好。
[主播] 哎呀。
[主播] 这本书。
[主播] 你看，先让孩子了解了他流经的这个部分。
[主播] 他主要的支流。
[主播] 了解了地理知识。
[主播] 又了解了沿途的城市，曾经重要的这些诗人，然后呢，还有一些重要的水力建筑。
[主播] 文化名城，对吧，人文知识，最后呢再把所有跟他相关的故事往块会总。
[主播] 我的天啊。
[主播] 这书太好了。
[主播] 这个是关于黄河的。
[主播] 白日依山尽，黄河入海流。
[主播] 欲穷千里目。
[主播] 更上一层楼。
[主播] 黄河远上白云间，一片孤城万人山。
[主播] 枪敌何须怨杨柳，春风不度玉门关。
[主播] 遥取黄河万里沙，浪淘风波自天涯。
[主播] 如今直上银河去，同到牵牛织女家。
[主播] 特别棒。
[主播] 还有将进酒非常经典的。
[主播] 君不见黄河之水天上来，奔流到海不复回。
[主播] 君不见高堂明镜悲白发，朝如青丝暮成雪。
[主播] 人生得意须尽欢，莫使金尊空对月。
[主播] 你看每句拿出来都是经典，都是绝片范围。
[主播] 喝。
[主播] 该还酒还酒。
[主播] 金招有酒金招醉。
[主播] 人生苦短，何必整天忧虑不欢。
[主播] 人生得意须尽欢啊。
[主播] 然后紧接下来就是天生我才必有用，千金散去还复来。
[主播] 花。
[主播] 花完了该来的会来的。
[主播] 烹羊宰牛且为乐，会需饮三百杯。
[主播] 曾夫子单求生。
[主播] 将进酒杯莫停，与君歌一曲，请君为我轻耳听。
[主播] 你看还有后面的这个古来圣贤皆寂寞，唯有饮者留其名。
[主播] 看牛了。
[主播] 黄河。
[主播] 卖咋样？
[主播] 不知道卖咋样。
[主播] 这本书卖卖出去的吗？
[主播] 卖出去了是吧？
[主播] 还有几本。
[主播] 这书是我在众多书里给他挑的。
[主播] 是吧？
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 然后大家以前也听过我们就说河东狮吼，对吧？
[主播] 河东是哪？
[主播] 你看这是黄河嘛。
[主播] 黄河以东是哪？
[主播] 山西嘛。
[主播] 所以河东地区就是黄河，那就是山西啊。
[主播] 宋代就在开封了，我们说这个苏氏嘛，对吧？
[主播] 开封府第一男神。
[主播] 司马迁史记。
[主播] 司马迁家是哪的？
[主播] 韩城。
[主播] 也是在黄河边的。
[主播] 渭南嘛。
[主播] 黄河边的。
[嘉宾] 你为什么喜欢这本书？
[主播] 当然了，这书是我从那众多书里挑回来的。
[嘉宾] 要不然你俩分别说说推荐理由。
[主播] 可以。
[主播] 我刚说的这套书的推荐理由就是第一个，让孩子了解了这个自然知识。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 三个阶梯是流经了多少省多少省市。
[主播] 然后呢，距离是多长。
[主播] 这些当然只是一个最基本的facts。
[主播] facts并不重要。
[主播] 紧接著应该是让孩子了解这个土地上曾经孕育过多少文明，曾经兴起过多少城市，曾经产生过多少历史的悲壮的故事。
[主播] 也让孩子了解了在这些故事城市和历史的长河中闪现过多少发著光的人，就如漫天星河里头闪烁的那一颗一样。
[主播] 然后让孩子感受这里人文的历史和苍桑的剧变之后，再去背一下这里的诗词。
[主播] 最后的落脚点就是开车带著孩子从上游一直开到下游，或者从下游一直开到上游。
[主播] 然后呢，这个过程里头，在每一座城市停留，感受品尝他的美食，然后最后参观这个城市的风景。
[主播] 聊一聊风土人情，让孩子理解这就是我们文化的根啊。
[主播] Cradle of our civilization,OK?
[主播] 明明你的推荐理由。
[嘉宾] 明明。
[嘉宾] 你看我的推荐理由，大家也说了，很多朋友在下边说明明就只能看这种小儿书。
[嘉宾] 不是看这个小儿书，我当时看的时候觉得大人也很需要，你知道吗？
[嘉宾] 现在你看这两天，这又到了暑假时间了，我们的那些前同事们开著车，骑著摩托车已经又进入西藏了。
[嘉宾] 然后呢，玩得非常开心，最讨厌的是天天还要发朋友圈，发这个抖音，让我们。
[主播] 对，就是你玩。
[嘉宾] 我也忍了。
[主播] 你还得让我知道。
[主播] 你让我知道就算了。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 还去不了。
[嘉宾] 你一冲动就一个字想说，辞职吧。
[主播] 辞职算了，我一般的方式就是把他们举报。
[嘉宾] 对对对，拉黑或者举报。
[嘉宾] 你这就是杨沙子本性，一直就没改。
[嘉宾] 然后呢，这个给大家找的这个书，我是觉得一是小孩看看合适，另外一个大人其实也很合适，比如说你像有这种你要是出去游玩啊什么的。
[嘉宾] 你就把这本这个书拿上。
[嘉宾] 把这个书直接放到车上。
[嘉宾] 坐在副驾驶的人翻一翻，一路走到哪，别光拍著拍照。
[嘉宾] 上车就睡觉，下车就是拍照。
[嘉宾] 上车睡觉，下车尿尿。
[嘉宾] 景点拍照。
[嘉宾] 真爽。
[嘉宾] 就就对，就不那么合适嘛。
[嘉宾] 你把这个书拿上边走边看。
[嘉宾] 比如说像那个董宇辉就很喜欢去大西北。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 大西北走的时候，走这个河西走廊，河西走廊这往过走的时候，我觉得就可以拿著这一个图册上面，不光是有地理的知识，还包含了太多太多的文化的知识，甚至连诗词都有，他这诗词还有专门附上了。
[主播] 对，这回。
[嘉宾] 嗯，这在这。
[嘉宾] 江州词。
[嘉宾] 然后呢，还有一本，你把长江介绍了吗？
[主播] 我大概说一下，不影响你继续说。
[嘉宾] 对，长江这个也很好。
[嘉宾] 你把地图呢？
[主播] 啥地图？
[嘉宾] 这打开不是有一张地图吗？
[嘉宾] 地图呢？
[嘉宾] 你是不是？
[嘉宾] 不是这个，不是这个。
[嘉宾] 他专门有一个可好看，你都真拿丢了是吧？
[主播] 这不是在这，在这，在这，在这。
[主播] 还好找到了。
[主播] 我就说还有一张图呢。
[主播] 图去哪了？
[主播] 要不然我又被过了。
[主播] 来来来，那个镜头怼近一点。
[主播] 给大家看一下。
[主播] 你说这两个老师能不能眼睛睁开？
[主播] 十名。
[主播] 你能不能照顾一下观众的感受？
[主播] 对著那个镜头来，123。
[主播] 哎呀，很努力了啊。
[主播] 老老老费劲了。
[主播] 尽力了。
[主播] 至少努力过，不遗憾了。
[主播] 对，人生重在过程体验。
[主播] 然后呢，来看一下啊，从长江的这个起源头从这，唐古拉山的北面，对不对？
[主播] 然后一路下来到这里边，每一个部分牵扯到它当地的这个地理啊，文化知识，包括你看啊。
[主播] 讲到这个长江这块的。
[主播] 宁江这，都江堰。
[主播] 嗯，这是非常伟大的工程。
[主播] 对，服了2000年。
[主播] 李冰父子。
[主播] 李冰父子修的。
[主播] 然后这个书上讲到这的时候，一会给大家翻看啊。
[主播] 你看从这往上太多太多的文化。
[主播] 乌江。
[主播] 然后往下还有包括那个三峡大坝，长江的一些发电站，水力上面全都有，最后到这来，一直到南京长江大桥，再往下，一直到入海口，到上海这进入海口。
[主播] 然后每一个部分的海拔的信息，对应的这些看几级阶梯啊，给大家再看一眼。
[主播] 三级阶梯啊。
[主播] 三级阶梯。
[主播] 然后都有详细的一个展示。
[主播] 再比如说往这啊，我想给大家展示一下那个。
[主播] 三连牙。
[主播] 对，三连牙，还有都江堰，都江堰，我觉得都江堰。
[嘉宾] 你果然是对小动物和小图片感兴趣。
[主播] 对对对对对，是的。
[嘉宾] 明明买了这本书去孩子，带著孩子去了一趟动物园。
[嘉宾] 丽江古城，看看。
[嘉宾] 去过丽江没？
[主播] 嗨。
[主播] 哎哟。
[嘉宾] 没有。
[主播] 我当然去过，我当年在那当高中主管的时候带著整个项目去的。
[主播] 爬玉龙雪山。
[主播] 去虎跳峡。
[嘉宾] 不说了，不说了。
[主播] 然后晚上呢，还吃酸菜。
[嘉宾] 你指定是没去过。
[嘉宾] 去过丽江都没有，都没有拯救你的爱情。
[主播] 我跟你说你已经完蛋了。
[主播] 把那个我们那个老师他哥开的，那这么大。
[主播] 这么粗一罐那大卖。
[嘉宾] 我昨天还仔细观察了一下这个图，我给大家推荐一个餐馆啊，在这呢，我给你们推荐一个馆子。
[主播] 说了，抱著门说话呢，当时。
[嘉宾] 就在这呢。
[主播] 推荐啥？
[嘉宾] 我给大家推荐一个餐馆。
[嘉宾] 就就在这，就在这个位置这。
[嘉宾] 有一家火锅特别好吃。
[主播] 烤肠。
[嘉宾] 可以。
[主播] 点到为止。
[主播] 浅浅。
[嘉宾] 你指望他们拿著这个图能找到还是咋的？还怕给人做广告是吧？
[主播] 这图都不一定真实。
[主播] 比例都不一定对。
[嘉宾] 导演还。
[嘉宾] 别别别。
[嘉宾] 别。
[嘉宾] 还怕给人发广告。
[主播] 他不是害怕给他做广告，他主要是害怕这个牵扯一些违规行为。
[嘉宾] 这是罪的。
[主播] 万一这不是一个正经场所呢？
[主播] 十名记得是个餐厅，我们做一考察，对吧，60岁以下观众请在父母陪同下进入。
[主播] 对吧？
[嘉宾] 然后然后再来看，这个比较重要的都江堰，都江堰，都江堰的这个原理解释的特别清楚啊。
[嘉宾] 这真的是非常伟大的或了不起的水力工程，2000多年以前就能够做出做出这样厉害的这个设计。
[嘉宾] 然后呢，他把这个尤其在汉气的时候，就水比较少的时候，让水走内江，然后去灌盖整个成都平原，四川盆地也叫成都平原。
[嘉宾] 然后在夏季雨水特别充分的时候，然后又害怕把这块给冲了，然后进行了一个分流，做特别好。
[嘉宾] 而且他厉害的，那会还有一点点物理原理，等那个就是在这个部分这炸了一个口，就是宝瓶口。
[主播] 宝瓶口。
[嘉宾] 这个宝瓶口在做的时候呢，竟然是把石头烧热，凉水一击，膨胀膨胀膨胀，对，把那个给掏出来。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 我刚讲过。
[嘉宾] 完了。
[嘉宾] 你都讲完了。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 因为我说没有用炸药也没有用大型机械，只是用热胀冷缩，所以山体没有被破坏，所以才能用2000年，要不然早都冲毁了。
[嘉宾] 好好好。
[嘉宾] 那都讲了是吧？
[嘉宾] 等等吧，你看这不管是从图片还是从画质，还是从他整个里边的语言表达，讲述的这些故事都非常非常有意思。
[嘉宾] 所以我觉得适合跟孩子一起读，当然你自己要是出去旅行啊什么，把这个带上也挺好。
[嘉宾] 放办公室看看也很不错啊，也很合适。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 好，这套也不贵啊。
[嘉宾] 两本下来是。
[嘉宾] 79。
[嘉宾] 两本下来79。
[主播] 对。
[嘉宾] 给孩子买一买。
[主播] 我吃的是我刚杯子里泡的我们自己东方甄选做的狗起。
[主播] 我刚一进泡了两杯，两包。
[嘉宾] 没有。
[嘉宾] 没了是吧？
[嘉宾] 狗起没有。
[主播] 行吧。
[主播] 还有啥？
[主播] 哎，烤肠有了。
[主播] 快快快。
[嘉宾] 烤肠。
[主播] 这个烤肠跟黄河有关的。
[主播] 我们可以讲一讲黄河。
[主播] 这个烤肠的这个黑猪肉来自河南。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 黄河下游。
[主播] 我们给大家说黄河造福的是哪啊？
[主播] 造福的是哪？
[嘉宾] 河套。
[主播] 是河套，是宁夏。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 对吧，是河套平原，是那。
[主播] 但是黄河到了河南之后呢，因为经常泛滥，所以造成了很多的灾害。
[主播] 但是我特别喜欢河南。
[主播] 我也去过很多次河南。
[主播] 我言寒就是河南。
[主播] 就是跟我跳那个舞那个人。
[主播] 你把他。
[嘉宾] 刚开始还有人说是我给你跳的，我说。
[主播] 你赶快澄清是吧？
[主播] 是不是赶快澄清？
[主播] 中丢人是。
[嘉宾] 不用澄清。
[嘉宾] 底下有朋友就已经说了。
[主播] 然后呢。
[主播] 所以我我我对。
[嘉宾] 隐形的翅膀。
[主播] 咋了嘛？
[嘉宾] 昨天放这个视频，我又想起咱们几年前在那，但我那会我记得不太清楚，但昨天看了那个又回回忆了一下。
[主播] 在炸水吗？
[嘉宾] 你那哪是隐形的翅膀，你那就是疯了的扑棱蛾子。
[主播] 扑。
[嘉宾] 介绍烤肠。
[主播] 那不当时孙老师让跳，我也啥办法。
[嘉宾] 你再不要啥事老往孙老师身上怪，孙老师那天就解释的都挺清楚，你就是那一个。
[嘉宾] 孙老师在上面唱歌，夸一下就站起来了。
[嘉宾] 就跟就呼应上了。
[主播] 我不是。
[嘉宾] 就现在那。
[主播] 我不是给老孙呼应，我是给许为呼应的歌呼应。
[嘉宾] 对对对对对。
[嘉宾] 你怎么解释都有理。
[主播] 你要那天换成其他人唱学，我也呼应呢。
[嘉宾] 来来来，快。
[嘉宾] 咱们还没有加入会员的，快加入一下会员。
[嘉宾] 200多个同事啊，宇辉就站起来了。
[嘉宾] 就跟台上的老孙就呼应起来了。
[主播] 你知道他兴奋的时候DNA都动了。
[嘉宾] 对对对。
[主播] 导演放一下曾梦想仗剑走天涯，快，我现在就要听。
[嘉宾] 什么歌？
[主播] 中石化常年合作伙伴。
[主播] 你一听你是不是想辞职？
[嘉宾] 然后老孙讲到那的时候，底下有些朋友就不停的在那刷，哇，宇辉太精明了什么什么。
[嘉宾] 我要给大家解释一下，宇辉其实不是那样人。
[主播] 哎，就。
[嘉宾] 单纯。
[嘉宾] 心机boy。
[嘉宾] 你咋现在反著整了？
[主播] 就是澄清不了，干脆抹黑。
[嘉宾] 杨沙子。
[嘉宾] 还是要澄清澄清。
[嘉宾] 不是不是那样。
[嘉宾] 他不是那样。
[嘉宾] 他为什么要站起来呢？你可以看一下。
[嘉宾] 静静的。
[嘉宾] 对，就是这个效果。
[主播] 哎呀。
[主播] 有很多朋友一直说。
[主播] 董宇辉你直播的时候能不能不要坐下？
[主播] 每天在我视频下面评论，董宇辉你能不能直播的时候不要坐下？
[主播] 快曾梦想仗剑走天涯放起来。
[嘉宾] 好。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 讲好长了。
[主播] 吃完烤肠就出发了。
[嘉宾] 我也吃一个。
[嘉宾] 我还没吃饭呢。
[主播] 你吃吗？
[主播] 没有手套。
[主播] 没找到。
[嘉宾] 你直接拿手指。
[嘉宾] 啊。
[主播] 哎。
[主播] 尴尬，手套在旁边没看见。
[主播] 不干不净，吃了没病。
[主播] 真的。
[嘉宾] 哎。
[嘉宾] 曾梦想不干。
[嘉宾] 不干。
[嘉宾] 只是放个歌这么困难吗？
[主播] 是因为咱们没有会员是吧？
[主播] 啊？
[嘉宾] 没有会员不放了。
[主播] 已经放了。
[主播] 我咋听不到呢？
[嘉宾] 已经放了。
[主播] 曾梦想仗剑走天涯。
[主播] 看一看世界的繁华。
[嘉宾] 放个隐形的翅膀吧。
[主播] 隐形翅膀昨天都放过了。
[主播] 这个烤肠咱们今天也是两个口味，对不对？
[嘉宾] 是的。
[主播] 原味的黑猪肉做的啊。
[主播] 黑胡椒味的是白猪。
[主播] 我听过许的现场。
[主播] 我当年还在大学的时候，隔壁西北大学建校110周年好像是。
[主播] 110还是120周年。
[主播] 然后呢，他去西北大唱了接近一个小时。
[主播] 当年的西北歌王。
[主播] 哎，你知道许威是在哪上的？
[主播] 高中部。
[嘉宾] 不知道。
[主播] 西光。
[主播] 我之前不是在韩森路带课的吗？
[主播] 韩森路小学。
[主播] 许威，我那学生跟许威是一个学校的。
[主播] 我就听过一次现场会。
[主播] 花180。
[主播] 给郑春补了一张票。
[主播] 180是站票吧？
[嘉宾] 反正特别靠谱。
[主播] 我其实买的好像是280。
[嘉宾] 我看的是孙燕姿。
[主播] 啊？
[嘉宾] 我看是周杰伦。
[嘉宾] 好多年前。
[主播] 最后出来喊的嗓子都哑了。
[主播] 你们你们放这个不对。
[嘉宾] 演唱会。
[主播] 没有会员，开不起原版是吧？
[嘉宾] 好。
[主播] 有年他开过一个西域在敦煌开的那个。
[主播] 哇，那个前奏天天的正好。
[主播] 噔噔。
[主播] 噔噔噔。
[嘉宾] 还是那句话，许威可能是原唱，也能是原告，你要这样谈下去。
[嘉宾] 他指定给咱告了。
[主播] 不会了，都是想挡。
[主播] 哥你。
[主播] 咱也忍不住这。
[主播] 都是该想挡，对吧？
[主播] 都是想挡啊。
[主播] 噔噔。
[主播] 你放那还是不行。
[主播] 你们这。
[嘉宾] 来回放不对是吧？
[主播] 不行你们这。
[嘉宾] 咱们好好给大家介绍介绍烤肠吧。
[嘉宾] 介绍一下烤肠啊。
[嘉宾] 烤肠我俩吃了，我刚吃了啊。
[嘉宾] 非常弹，这个烤肠咱们还没有拍过的朋友一定要。
[嘉宾] 赶紧下手买一下。
[主播] 叫西域，东西的西，遇见的玉。
[主播] 这是他当时在敦煌开那演唱会。
[主播] 你搜看有没有那个现场版。
[嘉宾] 好的。
[主播] 西域现场版。
[嘉宾] 所以我发现我站起来了。
[主播] 啊？
[嘉宾] 这可能是历史上首次出现了我来之后，人数跟你刚才那个有覆盖，然后有增加。
[主播] 烤试。
[嘉宾] 哥们要。
[嘉宾] 怎么说就掉了。
[嘉宾] 我还是坐下。
[主播] 是不是刚找到自信说这个他一来人数变高了。
[嘉宾] 然后迅速垮垮往下掉。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 就像观众说我必须证明一下给你看一下，要不然你还以为自己很说话，你就要我必须考个试给你证明一下。
[主播] 要不然你还以为教的很好呢，你感觉是吧？
[嘉宾] 来，还没有加会员的各位朋友，一定要再加一下会员啊。
[嘉宾] 加班会员，然后大家可以领到一个五块钱的券，还可以领一个满300减20,拿到这个券呢，就可以拍咱们这个自营的烤肠。
[嘉宾] 两个口味。
[嘉宾] 按照自己的喜好去选择。
[嘉宾] 还有些朋友可能稍微。
[嘉宾] 你看有朋友说贵，你给解释一下，为什么卖这么贵？
[主播] 黑猪肉。
[嘉宾] 什么四块钱一个？
[主播] 然后呢，黑猪因为生产时间长，300天呢。
[主播] 黑猪本来就贵。
[主播] 你去买黑猪肉，它的价格基本在白猪的这个三到四倍。
[主播] 然后我们的白猪为什么白猪是用的无抗生素的？
[主播] 无抗生素的话，就相当于你不能给猪打针。
[主播] 不打针的话呢。
[嘉宾] 没有抗生素，没有激素。
[嘉宾] 成本就是高。
[嘉宾] 对，另外一个还要给大家解释一下，其实不贵。
[嘉宾] 其实不贵。
[嘉宾] 咱们有些朋友觉得贵是你比较的对象没有选准。
[嘉宾] 你比如你选的是那种淀粉肠。
[嘉宾] 淀粉很多的那个火腿肠。
[主播] 其实不贵，其实不贵。
[主播] 咱们有些朋友觉得贵是你比较的对象没有选准，你比如你选的是那种淀粉肠，淀粉很多的那种火腿肠，然后稍微烤一下，那种有没有也有，那个卖的比较便宜。
[主播] 但是现在估计也得个两块两块五大概这样一个价格。但是如果你买的是这种纯纯的肉肠的话，它的价格通常是比较高的，在外边的便利店呀，旅游景点啊，街道拐角一般得要六块吧，六块六块钱大概啊。
[嘉宾] 你怎么会买六块的肠呢？
[主播] 的偶尔。
[嘉宾] 你朴素一些，咱们在创业阶段呢。
[主播] 对，咱就在这吃就行了。真的是。
[主播] 99块钱。
[主播] 三盒。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 三盒是24根，下来三块多吧，还可以了。
[主播] 导演还是没放，是吧？
[嘉宾] 你这还是没放，是吧？
[主播] 对。然后呢，给给放一下，不行就引擎翅膀，你那个实在放不出来，把引擎翅膀给放放一下。
[嘉宾] 你说此时此刻演唱会。
[主播] 不是没有库存啊，可能有些朋友所在的地方，咱们现在的原则是这样啊，就像我们
[嘉宾] 你这有先讲，我看一下音乐去。
[主播] 好好，你先看音乐。